la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 et dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Geneviève Darius sec
ministre délégué chargé des personnes
handicapées
madame la Présidente
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs
le retour du projet de loi de finance de
la sécurité sociale pour 2023 en seconde
de lecture devant votre assemblée me
donne l'occasion
au nom du ministère des solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
et du ministère de la Santé de la
prévention dans saluer l'importance et
l'ambition
l'importance pour nos concitoyens de
tous les âges et de toutes les
situations de vie
l'importance pour les professionnels qui
les accompagnent des premiers au dernier
jour de la vie à fortiori dans le
contexte d'incertitude et de tension que
nous connaissons
l'inflation
les pénuries de professionnels et les
doutes quant aux grandes transformations
en cours se ressentent dans de nombreux
secteurs
et le texte dont vous reprenez l'examen
constitue une part de la réponse
ambitieuse du Gouvernement en la matière
le premier rôle du PLFSS c'est d'abord
de financer
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie laond dame est ainsi
proposé à un niveau historique de 3,7%
hors dépenses de la crise sanitaire
cette augmentation conséquente s'inscrit
dans la droite ligne de l'effort
d'investissement que nous avons réalisé
ces dernières années notamment avec le
Ségur de la santé
pour soutenir l'hôpital face aux
épisodes hivernaux nous ajoutons un
milliard d'euros pour l'année 2022 comme
voté au sein de cette chambre cela
s'ajoute au 543 millions supplémentaires
pour faire face au surcoutes covid
adopté à l'Assemblée
grâce au sénateurs et notamment à la
rapporteur Imbert ce texte sécurise la
garantie de financement pour le second
semestre 2022
pour 2023 l'Assemblée nationale a créé
un dispositif transitoire de financement
des hôpitaux afin de permettre un retour
progressif à la normale
nous n'oublions pas la médecine de ville
alors que la négociation conventionnelle
s'ouvre elle fait aussi l'objet de
toutes nos attentions
mais nous ne perdons pas de vue nos
responsabilités après la crise ce PLFSS
en temps garantir la soutenabilité de la
sécurité sociale c'est pourquoi des
mesures d'économie juste et
proportionnées sont demandées à la
radiologie ou à la biologie
en ce qui concerne le secteur
médico-social
lambda m'accompagnera de 5,1% contre 4,3
en 2022 pour atteindre 30 milliards
d'euros
ce sont près de 1 milliard et demi
d'euros de financement supplémentaires
avec notamment 600 millions d'euros
dédiés au revalorisation salariales
c'est à dire aux suites du Ségur et de
la conférence des métiers ainsi qu'à
l'augmentation du point d'indice dans la
fonction publique et son extension au
secteur privé
500 millions d'euros pour le soutien de
l'accueil à domicile avec la réforme de
la tarification des services de soins
infirmiers à domicile et la création de
place pour réduire les refus de prise en
charge auxquelles certaines personnes
sont confrontées
200 millions d'euros pour recruter des
soignants en EHPAD ce qui nous inscrit
dans la trajectoire annoncée de
recrutement de 50000 professionnels sur
les prochaines années et enfin plus de
200 millions d'euros de compensation de
l'inflation
réponse ambitieuse donc avec des moyens
financiers conséquents inédits pour des
politiques de santé du Grand étage du
handicap et de la famille
mais le rôle du PLFSS c'est aussi
d'améliorer la vie de nos concitoyens et
de préparer l'avenir
je pense en premier lieu à la transition
démographique et qui est en cours dans
notre pays en 2030 un tiers de la
population aura plus de 60 ans
or le virage à domicile hier que la
majorité des Français appelle de leur
vœu est bien en cours et c'est pour cela
que nous faisons le choix tout d'abord
de renforcer les services de soins
infirmiers à domicile avec le
financement de 4000 nouvelles places en
cohérence avec notre trajectoire
d'augmentation de 20% d'ici à 2030
c'est pour cela aussi que nous ajoutons
deux heures de présence supplémentaires
chaque semaine pour les 780 000
personnes bénéficiaires de la part à
domicile
c'est comme cela que nous apportons de
la sérénité à des gestes de soins et que
nous aidons les professionnels à
retrouver le sens de leur métier
c'est pour cela encore que nous
renforçons la lisibilité de l'offre qui
est cruciale pour que les bénéficiaires
exercent un libre choix et un choix
éclairé
d'abord avec la poursuite de la logique
de guichet unique engagé en 2022 que
nous consolidons avec le forfait
coordination
ensuite avait l'introduction de
davantage de souplesse pour les
bénéficiaires de Lapa
je salue à ce titre le travail accompli
entre le gouvernement et le Parlement
qui a permis d'aboutir à une solution
appropriée en s'inspirant de ce qui
existe pour la prestation de
compensation du handicap la même
possibilité de report des heures non
utilisées sur six mois sera ainsi demain
appliqué au plan à pas
un autre résultat de dialogue de qualité
entre le gouvernement et les assemblées
c'est l'amélioration de l'accompagnement
financier des départements par la Caisse
nationale de solidarité de l'autonomie
les mesures de revalorisation des
rémunérations des salariés des aides des
services d'aide à domicile ont eu un
impact marqué sur les finances des
départements le gouvernement Anna ainsi
pris acte
je pense aussi évidemment aux mesures
relatives au handicap
l'augmentation de 5,2% de l'objectif
national de dépenses pour le volet
personne en situation de handicap est
inédite
elle nous permet d'accélérer la mise en
oeuvre de grands objectifs et de
politiques prioritaire il s'agit entre
autres de développer davantage les
relations entre l'école et les
établissements médico-sociaux par
exemple en renforçant la création de
services d'accompagnement à la
scolarisation en milieu ordinaire ou de
poursuivre le déploiement des unités de
scolarisation dédiée aux élèves polis
handicapés
de diversifier les modalités
d'accompagnement des personnes
handicapées vieillissantes pour
favoriser l'accompagnement dans leur
lieu de vie habituel
je pense aussi à la poursuite des
mesures concernant l'autisme et les
troubles du neuro-développement avec 80
millions d'euros prévus ces financements
permettront ainsi d'étendre au 7-12 ans
la politique de détection précoce
qui est l'une des réussites majeures de
la stratégie nationale et qui a permis
après de 30000 enfants depuis trois ans
d'être détecté à temps et donc
correctement accompagné
là encore le texte porté une ambition
forte dès l'origine amplifiée au cours
de la navette parlementaire et je pense
tout particulièrement à la création de
briques informatique nationale afin
d'harmoniser les systèmes d'information
des maisons départementales des
personnes handicapées et de faciliter
leur interopérabilité
ceux-ci simplement pour garantir une
meilleure équité de traitement sur le
territoire
de l'Université de l'universalité des
droits
j'exprime ici le vœu que nous
conservions à l'avenir un tel esprit de
co-construction dans la perspective de
la prochaine Conférence nationale du
handicap
dans ce PLFSS des mesures relatives aux
familles elle concerne en particulier la
réforme du complément de mode de garde
qui doit permettre à chacun et chacune
de pouvoir
occuper un emploi mais aussi lutter
contre les inégalités à la racine dès la
petite enfance
nous modifions ainsi le barème du
complément de mode de garde pour
permettre aux familles qui ne recouvrent
pas à la crèche de pouvoir faire garder
leur enfant au même coup par une
assistante maternelle
de même nous étions le CMG au-delà de 6
ans et jusqu'à l'entrée au collège pour
les familles monoparentales
l'engagement du gouvernement aux côtés
des familles à monoparentales dont 30%
vivent dans la pauvreté et 90% sont des
femmes et totale il passe aussi depuis
le 1er novembre par l'augmentation de
50% de la pension alimentaire minimale
cette mesure doit faire baisser le taux
de pauvreté des familles monoparentales
de 2,2 points
à cela s'ajoute les créations de
nouvelles places d'accueil pour combler
les 200 000 placements compte d'ici 2030
nous savons que 160 000 parents ne
reprennent pas leur travail faute de
solution
c'est donc l'enjeu d'égalité des chances
de développement pour les enfants
d'accès à l'emploi et de conciliation
entre vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle pour leurs parents
ces mesures forment la première pierre
du service public de la petite enfance
engagement de campagne du président de
la République qui s'inscrit dans la
droite ligne de ce qui a été fait avec
les 1000 premiers jours nous y
travaillerons avec responsabilité et
ambition tout au long de ce quinquennat
avec les collectivités locales
permettez-moi maintenant d'en venir
voler santé
en la matière la première vocation de ce
texte c'est d'améliorer l'accès à la
santé pour tous
nous capitalisons donc sur les mesures
d'urgence prises cet été le président de
la République l'avait annoncé et c'est
une mesure forte face au territoire
soudoté nous exonérons de cotisations
retraite les médecins retraités qui
souhaiteraient continuer à s'engager
dans notre système de santé
nous actionnons également plusieurs
leviers pour reconquérir du temps
soignant dans tous les territoires je
pense tout d'abord à la création d'une
quatrième année de consolidation au
diplôme d'études spécialisées de
médecine générale
un véritable projet pédagogique
permettra durant cette année
supplémentaire d'internat d'accompagner
les futurs médecins à leur installation
rapide
une mission lancée conjointement par le
ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche et le ministère de la
Santé de la prévention
permettra par ailleurs de concerter avec
l'ensemble des partis prenantes sur les
conditions de succès de cette réforme
nous souhaitons également à l'heure où
s'ouvrent les négociations
conventionnelles et créer un cadre plus
adapté
cela permettra d'accompagner pleinement
les engagements réciproques qui feront
l'objet des discussions dans le cadre du
CNR santé
l'objectif est d'améliorer la réponse
aux besoins de santé dans les
territoires et de créer les conditions
dans renforcement du temps soignant dans
les zones soudances
enfin nous simplifions et nous
renforçons la politique d'aide à
l'installation
le gouvernement entend harmonisé les
dispositifs d'aide en renvoyant
l'ensemble de ceux qui sont portés par
l'État aux champs conventionnel sauf
pour les étudiants et les remplaçants
en parallèle les territoires seront
invités à généraliser des guichets
uniques pour apporter plus facilement
des réponses concrètes à toutes les
questions que se posent les jeunes
médecins avant de s'installer en libéral
enfin il faut souligner que ce PLFSS
permet de se projeter au-delà de l'année
à venir
il a ainsi pour ambition de remettre
durablement l'éthique au cœur du système
de santé
il en va ainsi du recours à l'intérim
malgré une volonté de la part des
pouvoirs publics de mieux le réguler
il a pris trop d'importance avec un coût
financier inacceptable à l'heure où nous
devons rééquilibrer les comptes de la
sécurité sociale
surtout il engendre une déstabilisation
des services et des équipes notamment
dans les territoires démographiquement
fragiles en professionnel de santé
ce PLFSS renforce donc la régulation de
l'intérim
et je veux rappeler l'amendement du
groupe RDPI qui permet d'appliquer les
mesures du PLFSS aux entreprises
intérimaires situées à l'étranger
cette évolution ira de père avec les
travaux à engager sur l'accompagnement
des débuts de carrière au service des
jeunes professionnels
enfin ce PLFSS transforme le système de
santé en accélérant le virage préventif
et cela passe par plusieurs mesures
importantes
les rendez-vous de prévention aux âges
clés de la vie constitue une innovation
majeure
vaccination dépistage des cancers santé
sexuelle habitudes de vie dépistage
auditifs et visuels santé mentale les
termes abordés au cours de ces
rendez-vous seront très larges adaptés
en fonction des âges selon une approche
globale de la santé de la personne
ces rendez-vous de prévention seront
intégralement prises en charge par
l'assurance maladie sans avance de frais
de façon à réduire les inégalités
par ailleurs le covid-19 l'a montré la
prévention c'est en grande partie la
vaccination
ce PLFSS prévoit donc sur la base des
recommandations de la Haute Autorité de
Santé d'étendre aux pharmaciens aux
infirmiers aux sages-femmes la
prescription et la réalisation des
vaccins
cette mesure permettra très concrètement
de simplifier le parcours des patients
en augmentant le nombre de
professionnels habilités à vacciner
ce PLFSS renforce également la
prévention en améliorant la santé
sexuelle
le gouvernement souhaite faciliter les
dépistages des infections sexuellement
transmissibles au-delà du seul VIH qui
pourra désormais se faire sans
ordonnance et sera intégralement
remboursé pour viser tout
particulièrement les jeunes de moins de
26 ans
enfin donnez le choix aux femmes de
disposer de leur corps c'est bien sûr
assurer le recours à l'IVG mais c'est
aussi s'assurer que la contraception
d'urgence soit accessible à toutes
nous proposons donc d'élargir à toutes
les femmes majeures la délivrance
gratuite de la contraception d'urgence
hormonale en pharmacie le tout sans
condition de prescription médicale
en un mot ce PLFSS concrétise notre
ambition de faire de la prévention un
pilier à part entière de notre système
de santé
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
voilà les premières briques que posent
ce PLFSS c'est un texte de
responsabilité c'est un texte qui répond
aux urgences aujourd'hui tout en
préparant les défis de demain c'est un
texte qui conserve certains de vos
apports qui signent que ce débat a été
fécond en première lecture dans votre
chambre je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
je vais donner la parole à Madame
Elisabeth Doisneau rapporteur général de
la commission des affaires sociales pour
10 minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales chers collègues
oui madame la ministre vous avez raison
c'est un texte important le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale c'est important pour deux
raisons la première c'est que c'est 600
milliards d'euros et que ces cinq fois
le budget de la défense je n'arrêterai
pas de le répéter pour dire combien
c'est important la deuxième raison c'est
que ça concerne l'ensemble de la
protection sociale des Françaises et des
Français et que cette en fait un
rendez-vous un rendez-vous important le
carrefour de la protection sociale pour
notre pays
après l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire sur ce projet de loi
l'Assemblée nationale a examiné ce texte
en nouvelle lecture les députés ont pu
débattre en séance de l'article
liminaire qu'ils ont amendé pour
coordination de la première partie
relative au compte de 2021 qu'ils ont
curieusement adoptés confort pourquoi
curieusement car cela signifie qu'ils
ont adopté l'article premier dans sa
version Sénat en suivant donc les
préconisations de la Cour des comptes
pour autant même après ce vote l'article
2 qui approuve le tableau patrimonial
n'a pas été amendé de ce fait l'un des
articles affiche donc un déficit de 29,5
milliards d'euros pour l'année dernière
et l'autre un déficit de seulement 24,3
milliards d'euros une telle discordance
est pour le moins curieuse et pourrait
amener le Conseil constitutionnel à la
s'interroger sur la sincérité de cette
disposition s'il en était saisi
enfin les députés ont examiné la
deuxième partie sur les contes de
l'année en cours essentiellement pour
adopter une nouvelle rallonge de Londres
2022 à hauteur de 500 millions d'euros
afin de compléter les financements
octroyés au système hospitalier afin de
compenser les surcoûts liées à
l'épidémie de covid-19 pour les
établissements de santé en 2022 la
rectification de long terme 2022 est
ainsi portée à 10 milliards d'un peu
plus de 10 milliards d'euros par rapport
au montant voté dans la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
2022 madame la ministre comme nous
l'avons constaté en commission cette
nouvelle révision est de nature à
conforter la grande prudence du Sénat
quant aux estimations du gouvernement
pour ce qui concerne l'enveloppe de 2023
qui n'est que de 1 milliard d'euros
une fois passé l'examen de ces cinq
articles la suite a été beaucoup plus
expéditive puisque le gouvernement a
engagé sa responsabilité à deux reprises
l'une au tout début de la troisième
partie l'autre au tout début de la
quatrième partie il n'y a donc eu aucun
débat en séance sur ces deux parties en
nouvelle lecture
et ni la partie recette ni la branche
maladie n'auront fait l'objet d'un
quelconque débat en sciences publiques à
l'Assemblée nationale lors de ce PLFSS
en première lecture comme en nouvelle
lecture
de ce fait madame la ministre c'est bien
ce que le Gouvernement a souhaité
retenir retenir qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui
or reconnaissons que les apports du
Sénat qui figurent dans ce texte sont
particulièrement modestes on retiendra
pour l'essentiel dans la partie recette
un abonnement à l'article 11 bis qui
aligne le régime social des rachats de
RTT et des heures supplémentaires pour
les entreprises de 20 à 249 salariés
sur le volet autonomie on s’élimira la
reprise d'un amendement de Bernard bonne
qui traduisait l'une des recommandations
du rapport sur le contrôle des EHPAD à
savoir le plafonnement du montant des
excédents pouvant être mis en réserve
enfin sur le volet maladie je signalerai
le maintien de la prolongation de la
garantie de financement des
établissements de santé on peut évoquer
aussi un amendement encadrant le
développement de la biologie médicale
délocalisée qui intervient lorsque le
prélèvement ou la phase analytique d'un
examen de biologie est réalisé en dehors
d'un laboratoire de biologie médicale je
précise enfin que comme notre rapporteur
de branches Corinne Imbert et notre
présidente Catherine Deroche l'avait
fortement souhaité le report de l'entrée
en vigueur de la réforme du financement
de la réforme de financement des
activités de soins de suite et de
réadaptation sera donc au 1er juillet
et c'est à peu près tout
et oui c'est à peu près tout il me
semble que c'est bien modeste pour ce
qui concerne les mesures véritablement
normatives je précise que les auteurs
d'amment trouveront dans le rapport
écrit un tableau qui retrace le sort de
chacun d'entre eux
évidemment
aucun des amendements les plus
significatifs adoptés par le Sénat a été
retenu
c'est le cas de l'article additionnel
défendu par René Paul Savary qui
introduisait pour améliorer l'emploi des
seniors et engager le redressement de
notre système de retraite c'est le cas
des différentes mesures que nous avons
proposé afin de restaurer un contrôle
parlementaire en cas de dépassement de
Londres et de son enveloppe covid 19 que
nous considérons sous-estimé c'est le
cas de l'amendement qui se contentait
d'accorder au ministre un pouvoir
supplémentaire celui de refuser une
convention médicale dont les
conséquences financières seraient
incompatibles avec l'ONDAM votée par le
Parlement
c'est le cas de la contribution des
organismes complémentaires d'assurance
maladie que nous souhaitions
matérialiser au sein de ce PLFSS je le
rappelle à hauteur de 300 millions
d'euros et c'est le cas de notre refus
du transfert de 2 milliards d'euros de
charges de la branche
vieillesse à la branche maladie
quant à la dame 2023 malgré les hausses
incessantes de celui de 2022 le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas estimé
nécessaire de le revaloriser à
l'occasion de la nouvelle lecture c'est
donc de nouveau le montant que le Sénat
a rejeté en première lecture qui revient
de l'Assemblée nationale
mais au-delà de ces marqueurs même des
apports plus modestes et potentiellement
plus consensuels n'ont pas été retenues
par exemple sur l'intérêt médical ou sur
l'encadrement des téléconsultation
au bout du compte même si nous avions
des points d'accord dans le texte
d'origine on peut considérer que ces
particulièrement maigres et pas toujours
respectueux des débats riches et sérieux
que nous avons eu pendant toute une
semaine
dès lors comme cela était là devenu la
tradition même si les circonstances sont
bien différentes il est temps de
constater que poursuivre la navette ne
servirait plus à grand-chose d'autant
que le gouvernement va très probablement
utiliser de nouveaux la procédure de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 en lecture
définitive et qu'il a déjà clairement
indiqué ce qu'il souhaitait retenir de
nos propositions
de ce fait la commission des affaires
sociales proposera au Sénat d'adapter
une motion tendance à opposer la
question préalable sur ce PLFSS pour
2023 afin de marquer nos désaccords sur
le fond et sur la méthode je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci Madame la rapporteur général alors
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Bernard jaumier
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain pour 6 minutes chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
ce budget de la mes chers collègues ce
budget de la Sécurité sociale est
intéressant évidemment parce que c'est
le premier du quinquennat et qui prend
place donc dans cette nouvelle situation
politique voulue par les Français au
mois de juin qui est
que du fait de l'absence d'une majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale les
mouvements politiques et nous les
parlementaires sommes invités à faire
preuve de compromis politique
depuis le début de cette législature
nous avons vu ainsi le gouvernement sur
des projets de loi passer des compromis
avec les républicains puisque c'est le
mouvement qui a l'Assemblée nationale
peut garantir l'adoption définitive d'un
texte et que par ailleurs le tropisme
vers la droite de la mouvance
présidentielle et de plus en plus nette
au fil du temps pour ceux à qui ça
aurait échappé
et nous arrivons au premier texte
budgétaire soumis aux 49-3 et donc la
question qui se posait
et la vérité que nous allions voir
apparaître c'est est-ce que le
gouvernement s'est converti à ce demande
de compromis des politiques des Français
par conviction ou au moins par réalisme
ou est-ce qu'au fond
subsiste la tentation de la brutalité
allions-nous avoir un 49,3 brutal et
autoritaire ou un 49-3 de compromis
politiques
et bien je crois que nous avons la
réponse
la réponse c'est que le travail des
oppositions a été balayé
aucun amendement de notre groupe
exactement
utile porté sur des thèmes d'intérêt
pour les Français
utile était adopté par l'ensemble du
Sénat assemblée qui elle malgré des
oppositions de fond entre les groupes
politiques à une pratique du compromis
politique et parce qu'il y a cette
partie pratique du compromis politique
nous avons su nous présenter des
amendements adoptés par nos collègues de
la majorité sénatoriale et bien le
gouvernement a balayé tout cela
et il revient la bouche en cœur pour
nous proposer une deuxième lecture
mais de qui vous moquez-vous
je vais vous dire de la volonté des
Français exprimés dans les zones au mois
de juin car vous tournez le dos à cette
volonté de compromis politique vous nous
assignez vous nous assignez à notre
identité propre en refusant tout travail
en commun et j'y viendrai sur des
articles de fonds et qui va profiter de
cette posture du gouvernement ce qui
jeudi soir dans les mystique de
l'Assemblée nationale
ce sont livrés à cette séance au sens
terrible
debout applaudissant les propos les plus
outranciers pendant que le bloc central
des oppositions de gauche et modérée
était silencieuse
c'est aux extrêmes que vous donnez
raison par cette posture politique ce
49-3 dans ces conditions-là sur le
budget de la Sécurité sociale vous
rendez un mauvais service à notre
démocratie politique et quant au fond
et quant au fond l'année dernière à
cette même tribune je formais le souhait
que les élections présidentielles soient
logés d'un débat sur la santé et de
nouvelles orientations en la matière
est-ce que ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale tire la leçon de la pandémie que
nous vivons encore aujourd'hui
aucunement
aucunement aucune disposition
est-ce qu'il porte ce que nous soutenons
totalement le virage de la prévention
annoncée par le ministre de la Santé
aucunement sur le tabac quand le scénar
rétablit le texte initial du
gouvernement le Congrès des buralistes
demande au ministre des comptes publics
de changer le texte et le gouvernement
revient sur sa propre position quand il
s'agit de protéger notre jeunesse par la
taxation des bières sucrées aromatisées
ou par les peuples comme ça a été
proposé par notre collègue Catherine
Cassia est-ce que le gouvernement ouvre
la porte rien du tout il balaye tous ses
amendements le virage de la prévention
n'existe pas
aujourd'hui alors où nous débattons des
professionnels de santé protestent
aujourd'hui ce sont les psychiatres
demain ce seront les infirmières après
une main ce seront les médecins
généralistes hier et demain c'est
l'hôpital public le monde de la santé
est en rébellion le monde de la santé
crie qu'il n'a pas les moyens de remplir
sa mission et on réduit l'ONDAM de
l'hôpital public en dessous de
l'inflation et on réduit l'ont d'âme des
professionnels de ville à la moitié de
l'inflation mais écoutez
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire du
cinéma ou pour perdre notre temps
la rapporteur a raison à quoi sert une
deuxième délibération dans ces
conditions vous avez balayé tout notre
travail vous ne souhaitez pas de
compromis vous usez légalement du 49-3
un objet constitutionnel qui vous est
confié mais l'usage que vous en faites
il est mauvais il est brutal et nous le
rejetons
[Applaudissements]
madame la Cohen pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 4 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en ouverture des
débats en seconde lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 2023
le ministre de la Santé annoncé une
rallonge de 543 millions d'euros pour
l'hôpital au titre de l'année 2022 cette
enveloppe doit permettre d'absorber
selon ses propos les surcoûts liés à
l'épidémie de covid-19 et de soutenir
l'hôpital et tous les personnels qui le
font fonctionner c'est 543 millions
viennent s'ajouter au 570 millions
débloqués pour faire face à l'épidémie
précoce de bronchiolite qui impose
actuellement une très forte tension sur
les urgences pédiatriques ces crédits
supplémentaires sont une bonne nouvelle
pour les services hospitaliers mais
pourquoi attendre d'être acculés pour le
faire pourquoi ne pas entendre et
reprendre nos propositions celles de
notre groupe en les inscrivant dans la
loi de financement de sécurité sociale
initiale à chacune de nos position
allant ce sens vous avez répondu par de
l'autosatisfaction mais preuve que votre
budget n'était passé extraordinaire que
ça puisque vous votez des rallonges et
même si nous saluons ces moyens
supplémentaires ils ne pourront couvrir
uniquement que le doublement de la
rémunération des heures de nuit pour
l'ensemble des personnels et le paiement
des heures supplémentaires jusqu'au 31
mars seulement ce qui signifie que ce
plfsh 2023 est marquée par une
insincérité financière que le
gouvernement souhaite sans doute
rectifier en fin d'année lors de
l'examen du PLFSS pour 2024 ce qui va
continuer à plonger l'hôpital dans une
situation explosive d'autant plus avec
un nom d'âme si bas en dessous de
l'inflation en réalité si ce PLFSS 2023
est remarquable c'est par toutes les
mesures urgentes qu'il ne contient pas
je n'ai pas la possibilité de toutes les
évoquer ici mais j'en citerai
quelques-unes rien pour combattre
véritablement les déserts médicaux les
inégalités sociales et territoriales de
santé aucune disposition pour combattre
la marchandisation des médicaments pas
de prise en compte de l'ampleur de la
crise de la paix de la psychiatrie et de
la pédopsychiatrie et là je pourrais
multiplier les exemples qui démontent
votre incapacité à anticiper et surtout
votre absence de volonté à renforcer à
redresser notre service public de santé
en ce 29 novembre journée nationale de
mobilisation et de grève dans le secteur
de la santé mentale je voudrais apporter
mon soutien et le soutien de l'ensemble
de mon groupe au personnel victimes
d'une crise sans précédent et ce dans un
silence assourdissant des tutelles
quatre organisations syndicales
réclament un Ségur spécifique face à
l'abandon de la psychiatrie qui subit
des suppressions de lit des fermetures
de centre médico-psychologiques une
pénurie très forte de personnel le
personnel soignant se dit dans
l'impossibilité d'exercer correctement
son métier il y a donc urgence à
revaloriser à investir le secteur de la
psychiatrie publique enfin je voudrais
interpeller une nouvelle fois
le gouvernement sur la nécessité de
réindustrialisation de
réindustrialisation de notre pays et la
mise en place d'un dispositif permettant
de reprendre la main sur la production
et la distribution de médicaments ce
dispositif que nous appelons de nos vœux
a pour nom le pôle public du médicament
il se décline au plan national et
européen il est urgent de le mettre en
place vous savez mes chers collègues il
y a une pénurie dramatique des
antibiotiques et singulièrement de
l'amoxicilline qui est un traitement
courant pour les enfants quand
allez-vous agir contre la toute
puissance de grand labos pharmaceutiques
qui décide de tout des prix des
molécules de la durée de vie de tel ou
telle traitement malheureusement pas
dans ce budget de la Sécurité sociale
alors si on ajoute à tous ces manques à
tous ces refus de sortir notre système
de santé de la tempête dans lequel il se
trouve le mépris des parlementaires que
nous sommes avec l'utilisation à quatre
reprises de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution pour passer outre les
débats de l'Assemblée nationale
de ne même pas garder en CMP les
propositions qui avaient recueillies
l'unanimité au Sénat il est impossible
de voter en faveur de ce PLFSS pour 2023
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Hainaut pour le groupe
Union centriste pour 6 minutes chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur général
je vais entamer mon propos par une
citation d'un humoriste que j'adorais
que j'adore toujours Raymond Devos une
mauvaise rengaine c'est un air qui
commence par vous rentrez par une
oreille et qui finit par vous sortir par
les yeux
et bien il en est ainsi du 49.3 et plus
encore de ce 49-3 qui retient très peu
de nos débats j'allais dire rien ou
presque rien parce que il y a 49-3 et
49-3 celui-ci est un 49-3 dans une
version rude dans une version hard comme
dirait les jeunes le PLFSS du Conseil
des ministres et pour le reste circuler
il n'y a rien à voir
les 49-3 répétitions sur les débats
budgétaires c'est un peu comme le poids
la gratter au début ce lâche chatouille
puis cela irrite et avec le temps cela
devient insupportable l'abus du 49-3
n'est pas illégale bien sûr mais il a un
défaut congénital par nature il assèche
l'envie j'allais dire le désir de
trouver des accords il assèche l'envie
et le désir de négocier l'envie elle
désire du débat de la discussion
parlementaire et de la co-construction
moi qui ne crains pas de revendiquer une
filiation avec feu le MRP je retrouve
cela tout à fait regrettable alors
j'entends ceux qui disent cela toujours
été comme ça c'est la cinquième
république peut-être mais d'abord j'en
suis pas totalement sûr et puis
pardonnez-moi je trouve cet argument
assez faible voyez-vous chers collègues
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être collègue de
Maurice Schuman au conseil régional du
Nord-Pas-de-Calais de 92 à 98 ah c'est
un temps témoins de 20 ans ne peuvent
pas connaître mais il manie à la
perfection la dialectique entre
l'égalité et légitimité je ne
développerai pas Alexer cette question
mais l'abus du 49-3 pose la question de
la légalité de la légitimité je sais que
cette dialectique doit être maniée avec
précaution avec nuance mais c'est un
sujet d'ordre constitutionnel il pose
aussi la question des marges de manœuvre
des ministres lors de la discussion
parlementaire vis-à-vis de Bercy c'est
encore un autre sujet voilà pour la
forme mais comme disait Victor qui siégé
ici même la forme c'est le fond qui
remonte à la surface et sur le fond
notre rapporteur général Elisabeth
Doisneau a dit l'essentiel je veux
simplement au nom du groupe UC insisté
sur quelques sujets qui nous tiennent à
cœur reconnaissant que nous n'est pas
ajouté dans ce PLFSS la majorité
sanatoriale d'ailleurs défendue des
actes structurant elle peut naître fière
je pense notamment aux amendements
portés par notre groupe et soutenu par
la majorité l'élargissement et
l'exonération de cotisations patronales
spécifiques à l'emploi saisonnier dite
Tod l'exonération d'impôt sur le revenu
et de CSG sur les chèques carburant
versé par les employeurs ou encore
l'annulation du transfert aux URSSAF des
cotisations agir Carco
le paritarisme c'est notre ADN et nous
en serons toujours les avocats madame la
ministre permettez-moi aussi de
regretter l'abandon d'amendements
concret sur la démographie médicale
l'intérim les biologistes ou encore les
télésons vous donner la priorité au
vieillir à domicile très bien nous la
partageons et donc fort de ce constat le
Sénat sur l'initiative du groupe UC
avait adopté un amendement pendant
accéléré le déploiement de deux heures
de temps social prévu dans le texte tant
pour les personnels des sad que pour les
bénéficiaires de la part surtout son
abandon définitif aurait permis son
adoption définitive regrette cette
abandon aurait permis de limiter la part
des dépenses à la charge des
départements au titre de la part il
s'agit d'un enjeu majeur de
soutenabilité de la dépense et de
l'ajuste compensation due aux
collectivités territoriales avec Valérie
Letard nous avions appelé de nos vœux
une réforme des concours de la CNSA pour
les départements là encore votre message
politique est limpide pas de soutien
envers notre territoire et départements
activités locales et territoriale qui en
ont pourtant fort besoin par ailleurs
vous avez aussi écarté la consultation
de l'ADF dans le cadre de l'alignement
de la forfaitisation de la passe sur les
modalités de forfaitisation de la PCH au
profit de la saisine du Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes
le refus de territorialisé et
regrettable sur cette question comme
tant d'autres le groupe UC vous le dit
n'est pas acceptable que l'État décide
et que les collectivités locales doivent
se contenter de payer j'en viens à la
politique familiale de ce belfss le
modèle de la famille française évolue il
a besoin du soutelin de l'État et d'un
véritable politique ambitieuse qui
accompagne et donne un cap or des jeunes
parents ne trouvent pas le mode de garde
à duploie pour leurs enfants de plus
vous rejetez l'amendement adopté par le
Sénat sur la suspension du versement de
la CSG de la CMG pardon qui ne sac aux
familles qui ne s'acquitent pas du
salaire de l'assistante maternelle je le
répète pour nous la politique familiale
n'est pas une politique sociale c'est
une politique familiale et de ce point
de vue vous ne nous empêcherez pas de
penser que le transfert des IJ de 2
milliards d'euros de la branche famille
vers la branche santé est un bien triste
symbole avant de conclure dans ce
tableau un peu sombre je vais évoquer de
lueur l'amendement sur le contrôle des
établissements et celui de Nathalie
Goulet sur l'obligation de verser sur un
compte domicilié en France ou dans la
zone c'est pas les prestations soumises
à condition de résidence vous l'avez
compris le groupe USC votre A7 question
peralables même si même si nous n'aimons
pas ce procédé par nature d'abord parce
que nous sommes perplexe vous l'avez
compris sur nos débats passés et leur
utilité et puis parce que nous n'avons
aucune illusion sur le l'utilité d'un
nouveau débat sur ce PLFSS et parce
qu'en matière parlementaire comme dans
la vie réelle nous n'avons aucun goût
particulier pour le vélo d'appartement
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup cher collègue la parole
est à Madame Véronique Guillotin pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique et
social européen pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de commission
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues cette nouvelle lecture
vient clore les débats du PLFSS qui ont
été marqués cette année par des
conditions d'examen particulièrement
difficiles de 49,3 l'Assemblée en
première lecture une semaine de
discussion au Sénat suivi de deux
nouveaux 49,3 l'Assemblée en nouvelle
lecture
si les débats au Sénat ce sont déroulés
avec le sérieux et le respect qui
caractérise notre assemblée nous avons
souffert de délai extrêmement contraints
le texte de l'Assemblée nationale ayant
été publié seulement hier soir nous
étions ce matin même en commission pour
examiner le rapport à peine quelques
heures avant le début de la séance le
budget de la Sécurité sociale est
pourtant cela a été dit le plus gros
budget de l'État et il mérite que l'on
s'y attarde c'est pourquoi comme chaque
année le groupe RDSE regrette mais
comprend le dépôt d'une motion tendance
à opposer la question préalable nous
comprenons ce choix effectivement
faisons-nous aussi le compte de peu de
mesures du Sénat retenues par le
gouvernement mais par principe le rds-
préférera poursuivre la discussion
considérant que dans un contexte
d'inflation des ordonnances tout
opportunité pourraient être saisie pour
autant reconnaissons également que le
gouvernement n'a pas créé les conditions
favorables d'une nouvelle lecture
certains apports votés par le Sénat
aurait effectivement pu être conservé
par le gouvernement notamment la
pérennisation du dispositif ténod
défendu de longue date par le RDSE et
d'autres groupes ou encore l'annulation
du transfert aux URSSAF du recouvrement
de plusieurs types de cotisations ou
encore des mesures de prévention
direction de la jeunesse Bernard jaumier
l'a rappelé toutefois nous partageons
des points de ce PLFSS dans la situation
de pénurie de praticiens que l'on
connaît dans l'attente des premiers
résultats espérons le positif du
numérique à Pertuis à pertu s'il est
nécessaire de trouver des solutions de
court terme c'est une nécessité absolue
pour alléger la charge de travail des
médecins qui restent et enclencher le
virage de la prévention nous saluons
donc les rendez-vous de prévention des
achetés de la vie tout comme l'accès
facilité au dépistage des infections
sexuellement transmissibles le cumul
emploi-retête plus avantageux permettra
par ailleurs au médecin qui le
souhaitent de prolonger leur activité
enfin et surtout le partage des tâches
permettront de libérer du temps médical
tout en améliorant l'accès aux soins via
les certificats de déc par les
infirmiers l'élargissement du nombre de
professionnels habilités administrer les
vaccins ainsi que l'accès direct aux
infirmiers en pratique à avancées sous
réserve et j'insiste de confier
l'application de cette mesure aux
équipes coordonnées sur le terrain je
veux parler des MSP des CPTs par
ailleurs nous constatons que l'ajout
d'une quatrième année de troisième au
troisième cycle des études de médecine
générale les débats ont porté leurs
fruits lors de l'examen de cet article
en séance j'ai défendu avec insistance
l'importance de garantir aux étudiants
l'encadrement par des maîtres de stage
des universités et la possibilité de
réaliser une partie du stage en milieu
hospitalier si je souhaitais qu'il soit
réserve aux hôpitaux de proximité je me
satisfais de ces précisions
indispensables qui rappellent avec force
que cette année supplémentaire et une
année de formation mais juste une année
de formation
pour autant le PLFSS n'a pas vocation à
changer en profondeur le système de
santé qui en attend besoin les médecins
libéraux seront en grève jeudi et
vendredi rejoignant la longue liste des
professionnels de santé à bout de force
dont les urgentistes pédiatres
sages-femme pharmacien ou encore les
laboratoires d'analyses je salis ici
leur travail et leur engagement il y
aurait tant à dire madame la ministre
sur le manque d'anticipation des
politiques de santé sur les aspirations
des jeunes générations qui ont bien
changé sur le manque de projection à
moyen terme qui pourrait être l'objet
d'une loi purie annuelle très attendue
sur l'indispensable révolution de la
prévention ou encore sur la place trop
importante de la tarification à l'acte
en somme une transformation en
profondeur amenée avec les premiers
concernés accompagnés d'un grand soir de
la décentralisation et seul en mesure de
relever le défi une gouvernance
territoriale composée de tous les
acteurs du soin des collectivités des
associations de patients à l'échelle
d'un territoire pour répondre aux
besoins et non à l'offre comme le Play
se plaît à lire le ministre Braun pour
toutes ces raisons le groupe RDS se
votre a contre la question préalable et
appelle de ses vœux une grande loi 2006
la parole est à Madame Corinne Imbert
pour le groupe les républicains pour 10
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur général madame et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
alors que le projet de voie de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 arrive à la fin du processus
législatif il est maintenant temps d'en
tirer des enseignements nécessaires tout
d'abord je tiens à remercier à nouveau
la rapporteur général les rapporteurs et
l'ensemble de mes collègues sénateurs
qui ont travaillé sur ce texte qui ont
beaucoup travaillé sur ce texte en effet
une fois de plus au Sénat a montré sa
capacité à enrichir et à améliorer le
texte qui lui était proposé loin du
tumulte de l'actualité l'ensemble des
groupes politiques qui composent cette
assemblée ont su apporter lors de cette
semaine d'examen en séance publique des
propositions cohérentes constructives et
argumentée
au-delà des désaccords politiques qui
nous séparent sur le fond et en cette
période trouble où la parole du
politique est souvent mis à mal je pense
qu'il est nécessaire de rappeler la
qualité de débat que l'on trouve au sein
de cette hémicycle nous vous aura pas
échappé mes chers collègues que c'est
uniquement dans l'hémicycle du Sénat que
le débat sur la branche maladie est donc
sur la santé a eu lieu en première
lecture au Sénat nous sommes employés à
enrichir ce texte de manière pragmatique
j'en veux pour preuve les différentes
mesures votées dans cette hémicycle nous
avons pris nos responsabilités
mon plus grand regret une nouvelle fois
le Sénat n'a pas été entendu par le
gouvernement et par la majorité
présidentielle et j'y reviendrai
alors que l'on dame 2022 avait été
supprimé à l'Assemblée nationale en
première lecture le Sénat a été
indulgent en réintégrant en dame 2022
dans le texte le débat c'est cependant
crispé rapidement quand dès le début de
l'examen du texte vous avez déposé
madame la ministre un amendement
relevant long terme 2022 de 600 millions
d'euros régularisant ainsi une dépense
réalisée entre le premier juin et le 15
septembre dernier mais que vous avez été
incapable d'afficher dans le projet de
loi initiale fin septembre 2022 que dire
de cette nouvelle augmentation de 500
millions d'euros inscrit dans le texte à
l'issue d'un nouveau 49.3 à l'Assemblée
nationale au total c'est une
augmentation comme la rappeler la
rapporteur général de 10,1 milliard
d'euros pour London 2022 par rapport à
l'andain voté dans la dernière loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale nous
comprenons mieux que vous nous
souhaitiez pas que le comité d'alerte
joue son rôle
nous avons rejeté la trajectoire
financière proposée par le gouvernement
jusqu'en 2026 loin d'être démagogique
cette suppression fait suite à l'absence
de plan stratégique au manque de
sincérité de cette trajectoire
financière nous avons du mal à croire à
un redressement de la trajectoire aussi
spectaculaire car il ne repose que sur
un effet recette anticipé mais revenons
au travail du Sénat en première lecture
pour 2023 travail marqué par de la
constance et de la cohérence de la part
de notre groupe comme souvent ces
dernières années nous avons voté la mise
en place d'une contribution solidarité
des organismes complémentaires
d'assurance maladie au bénéfice de la
branche maladie à hauteur de 300
millions d'euros loin de vouloir acculer
le Zoka nous souhaitons que l'ensemble
des acteurs de santé participent de
manière proportionnelle au défi posé par
la pandémie récente mais vous le refusez
nous avons supprimé le transfert de
charge de 2 milliards d'euros entre les
branches famille et maladie se transfert
que vous maintenez constituez un moyen
artificiel de diminuer les moyens
d'évoluer à la politique familiale et
traduit un manque d'ambition chronique
en faveur d'une politique familiale vous
vous entêtez dans cette voie
fidèle à notre tradition de défense de
l'agriculture française nous avons
pérennisé le système spécifique
d'exonération de cotisation et de
contribution sociale patronales pour
l'embauche de travailleurs occasionnels
demandeurs d'emploi du secteur agricole
vous faites le choix de prolonger le
dispositif quelques années je vous en
accord grâce nous avons par ailleurs
modifié la mesure d'ajout d'une
quatrième année d'internat en
substituant la rédaction du gouvernement
par celle de la proposition loi du
président Bruno retaillod proposition de
loi adoptée au Sénat en octobre dernier
cette rédaction nous apparaît plus
solide que pour le plan sur le plan
légistique et plutôt que de valoriser
une initiative parlementaire le
gouvernement s'est entêté à introduire
cette mesure dans le cadre du projet loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale je
préciserai sur ce point que la version
du texte issu du 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui permet à titre exceptionnel
pardon que le stage de quatrième année
puisse être réalisé par dérogations en
milieu hospitalier ou extra hospitalier
en rajoutant cette possibilité vous avez
dénaturé l'objectif initial de la mesure
et nous ne pouvons que le regretter
au-delà du fond la forme nous interpelle
également cette mesure telle que rédigée
ne relève techniquement pas d'un texte
financier mais d'un texte santé qui
modifie les études médicales et
l'organisation des soins ces dernières
années de nombreuses mesures qui ne
relevaient pas du champ d'une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ont
été introduites par les gouvernements
alors même que le Sénat lui-même quand à
lui est plus exigeant en bâtir d'y
recevabilité nous attendons une loi
santé mais il est vrai que nous
attendions aussi une loi grand âge et
autonomie et peut-être que nous allons
entendre attendre encore un moment
afin de faire face aux tensions sur
l'offre de soi nous avons voté une
mesure visant à mieux encadrer l'intérim
médical et paramédical en début de
carrière mais vous le refusez également
sur les pinots dossiers qui opposent le
gouvernement et les biologistes votre
méthode a voulu n'a pas été très
élégante vis-à-vis de avec la rapporteur
général nous avons proposé la mise en
place d'une contribution exceptionnelle
de 50 millions d'euros sur la seule
année 2023 cette solution constitue à
compromis raisonnable qui aurait été
accepté par les biologistes vous le
refusez vous entêtez à poursuivre dans
votre voix sous préta d'une rentabilité
record pour le secteur de la biologie
médicale
nous ne contestons pas cet état de fait
mais n'oublions pas que ces mêmes
biologistes ont été en capacité
d'investir énormément pendant la
pandémie afin de faire face à
l'explosion de la demande n'oubliez pas
sur ce sujet que c'est l'État qui a été
le prescripteur et que c'est aussi lui
qui a fixé les différents tarifs
nous avons également mis encadré
l'implantation des cabines de
téléconsultation et leur exceptions
accessibles accessibilité en effet
l'ubérisation de la médecine ne peut pas
constituer une solution de repli aux
difficultés rencontrées en termes
d'accès aux soins concernant l'hôpital
il était le grand oublié du texte
initial une loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale sans un financement de
l'hôpital il fallait quand même le faire
heureusement vous avez présenté deux
modifications à la hausse de long terme
2022 j'allais dire il était temps et
enfin grâce au Sénat et malgré votre
avis défavorable exprimée au sein de
cette hémicycle et je vous remercie de
l'avoir souligné madame la ministre le
texte sécurise le garant la garantie de
financement de l'hôpital pour 2022 et
prévoit un nouveau dispositif pour 2023
nous avons supprimé landerme 2023
également pour cause de sincérité
douteuses et par manque d'éléments nous
permettant d'apprécier la situation dans
son ensemble les ajustements à la hausse
de landame 2022 aurait dû vous inciter à
la réflexion
nous avons intégré également une clause
de retour devant le Parlement en cas de
dépassement de la dame de plus de 1% en
cas d'exercice en cours d'exercice par
rapport au montant voté en loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et en
cas de rétablissement de l'objectif dans
la suite de la navette
le Parlement ne peut se résoudre à
laisser ses pratiques perdurer dans un
souci de transparence et de lisibilité
des comptes publics le ministre de
l'action des comptes publics nous a
répété à plusieurs reprises lors de nos
débats que chaque euro comptait oui bien
sûr chaque euro compte madame la
ministre pourtant vous avez refusé la
proposition du Sénat de revenir devant
le Parlement et 1% de dépassement ce
sont 2,5 milliards d'euros
nous avons voté la création d'une
conférence nationale des générations et
de l'autonomie destinées à documenter
les besoins des personnes âgées et des
personnes handicapées afin d'entraîner
la décision relative au financement des
priorités qu'appellent ces constats
c'est un sujet qui vous est cher mais
néanmoins vous n'y adhérez pas les
mesures relatives à la branche autonomie
demeurent insuffisantes lors du passage
du texte au Sénat nous avions voté un
certain nombre d'amendements visant à
améliorer le contrôle des EHPAD ses
amendements n'étaient que la traduction
législatives des préconisations issues
de la mission d'information sur le
contrôle des EHPAD dont le rapport a été
présenté en juillet dernier par Bernard
bonne et Michel meunier vous annonciez
vouloir vous emparer du sujet vous avez
conservé un abonnement de notre collègue
Bernard bonne puisque des paroles nous
attendons maintenant des actes
enfin nous avons institué une convention
nationale pour l'emploi des seniors et
la sauvegarde du système de retraite et
prévoyant les termes d'une réforme
paramétrique dossier cher à notre
collègue René Paul Savary l'emploi des
seigneurs est trop souvent minimisé dans
notre pays
or il a des répercussions importantes
dans de nombreux domaines dans
l'économie la cause intergénérationnelle
la transmission du savoir la santé de
nos aînés regardez l'évolution de notre
démographie la question du travail des
seniors demeure prépondérante concernant
la pérennisation de notre système de
santé nous attendons que les promesses
du gouvernement se matérialisent autour
d'un texte ambitieux et pragmatique
voilà madame la ministre un tour
d'horizon des principales mesures votées
par la Chambre haute ces mesures ne sont
ni démagogiques ni réalisable elle
s'appuie sur un travail sérieux mener
lors de dizaines d'auditions de
rendez-vous ces dernières semaines ma
question est donc simple je reprenais je
reprendrai pour cette occasion une
partie une partie je dis bien du titre
d'une chanson de Charles Trenet que
reste-t-il que reste-t-il du texte du
Sénat sans suspense et cela a été dit il
ne reste rien ou si peu et c'est vrai le
49.3 évoqué par nombre de mes collègues
change tout j'allais dire il chamboule
tout nous vous tendons la main en
choisissant la voie de la raison et vous
préférez une posture nombriliste qui
n'aurait rien de bon pour l'examen de
futur texte au Parlement vous l'aurez
compris madame la ministre alors que les
professionnels de santé les
professionnels du médico-social sont à
bout de force le constat décevant et
toute cette semaine de travail balayé
d'un revers de la main nous laisse un
goût amer
aussi le groupe les républicains votera
la motion proposée par la commission des
affaires sociales je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Daniel Chassin
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 4
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la remporté général Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs madame la
Présidente de la Commission mes chers
collègues ce pdfss apporte pour moi des
avancées pour les hôpitaux et nos
concitoyens pour l'hôpital avec une
augmentation longame de 3,7% covid cela
pour le personnel et l'investissement
entre 2012 et 2017 l'augmentation de
l'ONDA mettait de 2% je me permets de le
rappeler concernant l'augmentation de
cette ondame 57 milliards entre 2017 et
2023 c'est beaucoup il faut indiquer que
le covid est passé par là avec 18 points
milliards en 2020 15 en 2021 le Ségur de
la santé que nous avons tous approuvé
a augmenté du salaire des soignants
183 euros et presque 300 euros pour les
aides-soignante pour une somme de 13
milliards par an dans les hôpitaux il y
a un manque de personnel c'est vrai mais
souvent beaucoup de postes sont financés
ne trouvent pas preneurs pour les
médecins les infirmiers les aides
soignants comme l'indiqué le ministre en
grand plan national de formation
d'infirmiers des soignante et aussi de
médecins mais malgré l'ouverture du
numérique aux usine pas avant plusieurs
années pour les soins la quatrième année
d'internat dans les zones soudances mais
ça aussi c'est seulement en 2027 et je
le répète la rémunération de nos
internes pour cette dixième année doit
être suffisante et devrait être égal à
une consultation mensuelle à hauteur de
l'équivalent de 10 consultations par
jour soit 5000 euros par mois dans le
médico-social et surtout on n'est pas
nous aurions espéré beaucoup plus de
propositions d'emplois vu la grande
dépendance qui nous attend et des
partenaires actuel puisqu'il y aura deux
200 000 personnes
âgées dépendant de plus entre 2020 et
2030 c'est donc une déception de ce
pdfss mais nous avons écouté
attentivement le ministre de l'économie
qui nous a promis dans cette émission 50
000 emplois pour le quinquennat et vous
avez Madame le Ministre renouvelé cela
il y a des avancées pour les familles
avec l'âge des conjugués
conjugalisés là pas à domicile en hausse
l'augmentation du complément mode de
garde la détection précoce du trouble du
neurologue de développement
l'augmentation des pensions alimentaires
minimales et pour la prévention trois
visites préventives à déjà des âges clés
de la vie dépistage des infections
sexuellement transmissibles et du VIH la
pilule du lendemain gratuite pour toutes
les femmes sans ordonnance et encore les
vaccins sur prescription des pharmaciens
des infirmières et des sages-femmes
l'expérimentation aussi d'un accès
direct aux infirmiers en pratique
avancées dites à part en collaboration
avec le médecin et aussi mobilisation
des médecins retraités avec exonération
des cotisations retraite tout cela me
paraît utile j'ai voté à titre personnel
pour l'objectif d'équilibre des comptes
de la branche retraite en prévision des
fichiers de 12 milliards d'euros en 25
et 15 en 2026 mais cela bien sûr après
le dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
et ne pouvaient pas figurer dans ce
pdfss madame le reporter souhaite
maintenir le suivi de l'OM à l'année où
j'y suis favorable j'aurais souhaité que
l'amendement du Sénat concernant agir
Arco soit retenu mais malgré tout pour
moi ce pdfss a des avancées il me
paraissait possible d'avoir une CMP
conclusif
pour ce PLFSS 2023 cela n'a pas été le
cas et dans cet esprit les
parlementaires pourraient aussi
consacrer un peu plus de temps pour
essayer de s'entendre sur ce texte les
indépendants s'abiendront ou votre
rencontre la question préalable merci
[Musique]
de toi pour 4 minutes chers collègues
même pour ces mots c'est à vous merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur mais chers
collègues le désaccord entre la majorité
relative à l'Assemblée et le Sénat en
CMP qui nous a conduit qui nous conduit
à rediscuter ce texte nous a surpris
tant il semblait que la majorité c'est
notoriale s'était mise quand même au
diapason avec le cœur de vos projets
notamment en vous proposant de repousser
l'âge de départ à la retraite le
gouvernement a décidé néanmoins de
repousser de quelques semaines cette
échéance Argan de l'existence d'une
concertation dont c'est d'avance le sort
qui lui sera réservé ainsi après 4 49,3
le gouvernement aime rappeler qui
n'obéit aux jeux de la démocratie que
lorsqu'ils en fixe lui-même le cadre et
les règles ainsi le texte que nous
retrouvons ici est un vrai camouflé pour
la démocratie parlementaire dont le sol
tort est de vouloir jouer son rôle
législatif si nous saluons les quelques
avancées que le gouvernement a consenti
à conserver dans
49.3 comme alors important quand même la
compensation par l'état des exonérations
de la prime de partage de la valeur des
précisions apportées au rendez-vous de
prévention correspondant aux grandes
parties à ce que nous avions souhaité
l'ajout d'une feuille d'une phase
transitoire après la fin de garantie de
financement pour permettre aux hôpitaux
publics de renouer avec leur activité ou
bien encore effectivement la suppression
de l'article repoussant l'âge de départ
à la retraite presque reste que nous
déplorons que beaucoup d'ajouts du Sénat
étaient quasi systématiquement supprimé
y compris ceux à en jeu très modeste et
ce sans justification
par contre majeur la chambre haute avait
rejeté avec raison le transfert de plus
de 2 milliards d'euros de charges de
l'assurance maladie à la branche famille
excédant plus qu'utile à la mise en
place de politique en faveur des
familles modestes beaucoup plus
ambitieuses que celles contenu dans ce
pays FSS qui se restreint et c'est bien
au seul mais où ce qui se restreint aux
seules familles monoparentale alors
qu'un enfant sur cinq est en situation
de pauvreté en France le Sénat avait
aussi apporter des premières réponses
aux impayés touchant les assistantes
maternelles en attendant l'instauration
d'une garantie de salaire de la branche
mais c'est déjà trop le Sénat avait
supprimé l'article 44 qui permettait une
extrapolation à partir des indus
constatés et ainsi exiger des pénalités
aux établissements de santé sur des
dossiers non contrôlés un renversement
de la charge de la preuve pour les
établissements sur lesquels pèsera la
charge de prouver la non pertinence de
cet extrapolation
ses avancées ont été balayés même si
enfin le gouvernement a consenti une
rallonge de Londres hospitaliers que
nous avions défendu en vain au Sénat et
ce pour une meilleure prise en charge
des surcos covid la rectification
partielle de l'OM 2022 ne suffit pas à
masquer un nom d'âme 2023 qui ne
rattrape pas le retard des budgets
précédents d'autant que l'inflation
persiste et pèse sur l'investissement et
de fonctionnement que la covid amène des
milliers de personnes toujours par an
dans les hôpitaux publics et que les
mesures d'urgence du rapport Braun sont
prolongés alors qu'elle devrait être dès
à présent pérennisé nous sommes les
avancées que nous avons cité le PLFSS
2023 souffre toujours d'un manque
d'ambition pour relever les défis de la
transformation de notre système de santé
s'affranchissant enfin de logique
comptable à très court terme
alors pour ces raisons le groupe
écologiste votera à nouveau contre ce
PVF mais de façon préalable nous et nous
nous en expliquerons nous voterons nous
abstiendrons sur la notion sur la notion
présentée par le rapporteur général
voilà
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Martin lévrier pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 4
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
en nouvelle lecture après échec de la
commission mixte paritaire les députés
ont adopté sans vote la partie recette
du palais FSS après un recours à
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution par
madame la Première ministre le nouveau
texte sur lequel le gouvernement a
engagé sa responsabilité est ainsi quasi
identique à celui adopté en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui bien que la majorité
sénatoriales dépose une motion tendante
à opposer la question préalable
considérant que subsiste des points de
désaccord sur des questions décisives
nous pouvons nous réjouir que
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas retenu
l'amendement des réformes des retraites
présentées par notre collègue René Paul
Savary en effet si les pistes retenus
sont intéressantes le gouvernement s'est
engagé dans une concertation avec des
partenaires sociaux pour déterminer les
critères devant présider à une réforme
il est nécessaire d'atteindre l'issue de
ces discussions pour trouver les
meilleurs moyens de préservation de
notre le système de retraite auquel nous
sommes tous attachés de la rallonge de
543 millions d'euros destinés aux
hôpitaux pour couvrir les surcos
liocovie en 2022 de la conservation des
deux améliorations apportées par notre
groupe en premier lieu l'expérimentation
pour une durée de 3 ans du versement au
médecin en complément de la rémunération
à l'activité d'un forfait financé par
les fonds d'intervention régionales un
territoire ultramarin il prendra part
afin de garantir la diversité des
territoires investis dans ce dispositif
ainsi que leur représentativité en
second lieu l'extension de la condition
de durée minimale l'exercice dans un
cadre autre que des missions
d'intérimaires pour les professionnels
de santé mise à disposition auprès d'un
établissement de santé en France dans le
cadre d'un contrat conclu par une
entreprise de travail temporaire établi
à l'étranger
en responsabilité le Sénat avait
réintroduit l'annexe B qui a pour
vocation de donner une visibilité et une
stratégie pour l'avenir cette mesure a
été conservée à l'inverse des articles
tout aussi pertinents avaient été
supprimés dans notre émission et ont été
réintroduits au cours de la navette je
pense notamment à l'article 24 pardon 24
TER qui permet l'expérimentation de
l'accès direct aux infirmiers en
pratique avancées en structure
d'exercices coordonnées un décret devant
préciser après avis de la Haute Autorité
de Santé les modalités de cette
expérience et je pense bien évidemment à
l'article 47 le vote en hémicycle a
suivi la Commission en rejetant les
amendements de suppression de cet
article mais la majorité sénatoriale
n'étant pas un paradoxe près a ensuite
fait voter la suppression de ce même
article et éliminer de fait l'ONDAM 2023
fixée à
244,1 milliard d'euros faisant fi de
tous les efforts financiers du
gouvernement en faveur notre système de
santé
bien qu'elles veulent mettre fin au
débat la droite sénatoriale pourra se
réjouir de la conservation de l'article
8 qui inquiès relative à la taxe soda
moduler en fonction du taux de sucre
contenu dans les boissons concernées et
de la conservation de l'amendement
sénatoriale visant à inciter les
entreprises à se saisir des dispositifs
de rachat de RTT
cela étant nous ne pouvons que regretter
qu'un texte si important pour les
Français madame la ministre l'a très
bien résumé dans son discours de
présentation ne puisse pour la sixième
année consécutive pour suivre son
cheminement dans la navette
parlementaire pour ce faire il faut une
volonté partagée or la majorité
sénatoriale en rejetant l'ONDAM en
première lecture et de telle manière ne
laissez pas présager une forte envie de
discussion notre attachement au débat
parlementaire l'emportant sur toute
considération c'est sans surprise que
nous voterons contre la question
préalable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close passons à la
discussion de la motion tendante à
opposer la question préalable
Madame Elisabeth Doisneau au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales a
déposé une motion distribuée sous le
numéro 6 tendante à opposer la question
préalable au texte en discussion donc la
parole est à Madame la rapporteur
général doit non pour la motion et pour
10 minutes maximum ça va être cool
madame la Présidente ça devrait être
court madame la ministre la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
chers collègues ce matin réunis la
commission des affaires sociales a
décidé de proposer de proposer la
question préalable à l'ensemble de la
chambre haute et donc je vais rapporter
peut-être quelques exemples quelques
raisons qui nous ont amenées à apprendre
cette décision en réalité même si nous
avons des points d'accord et ça a été
rappelé dans l'expression de certains de
nos collègues il y a tout de même une
certaine frustration à voir que le
travail d'une semaine ici au Sénat était
balayée très rapidement par le
gouvernement on a donc considérer que il
manquait un certain nombre
d'éléments que nous avions défendu
pendant quelques jours ici alors
considérant que que si un accord est
intervenu entre les deux assemblées sur
certains articles du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale des
points de désaccord subsistent sur des
aspects essentiels considérant que le
texte considéré comme adopter en
nouvelle lecture reprend le montant de
l'ONDAM pour 2023 que le Sénat rejeté en
première lecture en considérant qu'il
était sous évalué considérant de
surcroît qu'aucune des mesures de
régulation ou de renforcement du
contrôle du Parlement en cas de
dépassement de l'ONDAM n'a été intégré
dans ce texte
considérant que la trajectoire
financière quadriana le présentée par le
gouvernement est incompatible avec
l'objectif d'un purement de la dette
sociale au 31 décembre 203
considérant que le transfert de 2
milliards d'euros de charges de la
branche maladie vers la branche famine
ne se justifie pas et risque même de
pénaliser comme ça a été dit par mon
collègue rapportant de branche l'action
de cette dernière branche des familles
considérant qu'il est indispensable que
le Parlement se prononce sur le montant
des dotations que les régimes
obligatoires de base de sécurité sociale
vers ce au fond aux organismes et aux
agences ce qu'ils subventionnent
considérant qu'il est nécessaire
d'affirmer dès à présent la nécessité
d'améliorer l'emploi des seniors et de
corriger les déséquilibres structurels
de la branche vieillesse et de mobiliser
l'ensemble des parties prenantes à cette
fin dans les meilleurs délais
considérant enfin que l'emploi
systématique par le gouvernement de la
procédure définie à l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution ne permettra pas
l'intégration de nouvelles propositions
du Sénat en lecture définitive le Sénat
décide donc qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
poursuivre la délibération sur le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture
merci même là porteur général quelle est
la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre
sans surprise la vie du Gouvernement est
défavorable
merci alors je vais passer la parole à
Madame ponce pour explication de vote
chers collègues
merci Madame après la présidence alors
le texte que l'on nous propose de
discuter revient au Sénat après un
nouveau 49.3 devant l'Assemblée
nationale mais aussi en supprimant une
grande partie des amendements votés au
Sénat si nous approuvons nous l'avons
dit quelques avancées comme le maintien
de la compensation par l'état des
exonérations de la prime de partage de
la valeur la rallonge le long dame
l'inscription d'une phase transitoire
face à la fin de la garantie de
financement pour l'hôpital public reste
que la question préalable au-delà de
considérant que le groupe écologiste ne
partage pas pointe un désaccord profond
sur la méthode car quelle que soit les
accords et des accords que l'on peut
avoir elle va être les amendements qui
ont été adoptés au Sénat durant la
première lecture bien sûr je rappelle à
titre d'exemple notre opposition résolue
à la demandement relatif aux retraites
reste nous nous trouvons face à un
gouvernement qui méprise le travail
parlementaire et il n'est pas
envisageable que le Sénat délibère de
nouveau sachant que le gouvernement
infini n'entend pas partager le pouvoir
législatif des apports même d'enjeux
mineurs de la chambre haut sont ainsi
été balayés sans explication les nôtres
comme ceux d'autres groupes c'est
importation au Sénat de l'esprit du 49.3
brutalisent le Parlement et présente un
vrai danger en bafouant la démocratie
parlementaire il l'affaiblit c'est une
forme d'anti parlementarisme ainsi ils
ne sont pas que nous soyons dans des
conditions favorables pour entamer
sereinement une deuxième lecture et il
est difficilement acceptable d'entamer
notre travail dans la perspective que le
Parlement sera encore déconsidéré du
fait de notre désaccord sur plusieurs
considérons de fonds le geste le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
s'absiendra sur la question préalable je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame à poursu poli
merci madame la Présidente le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste ne votera pas cette motion
pendant au rejet de la question
préalable même si nous avions déposé
nous-même une motion en première lecture
que vous auriez pu voter parce que
finalement qu'elle perde de temps la
majorité sénatoriale et le gouvernement
n'ont pas réussi à se mettre d'accord
sur le contenu du budget de la Sécurité
sociale pour 2023 mais en réalité on le
sait c'est un jeu de dupe d'un côté le
gouvernement campe sur ses positions et
refuse toutes les modifications
apportées par le Sénat y compris celle
adoptait à la quasi inanimité comme le
refus de transférer à l'URSSAF le
recouvrement des cotisations des
retraites complémentaires des cadres de
l'agir Carco ou sur le refus de
transférer de milliards d'euros de la
branche maladie à la branche famille de
l'autre la majorité sénatoriale défend
l'hôpital public alors qu'elle adopter
l'objectif national de dépenses de
l'assurance maladie pour 2023 qui est
inférieur aux besoins des établissements
et bien en deçà rappelons-le de
l'inflation en réalité le gouvernement
et la droite sénatoriale marchant
ensemble pour attaquer nos retraites et
se sont donnés rendez-vous à la rentrée
2023 et oui pour allonger la durée de
cotisation à 43 annuités si vous voulez
bien me laisser finir après je vous
écouterai et puis vous pourrez dire ce
que vous avez à dire pour allonger la
durée de cotisation à 43 annuités pour
reculer l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans pour maintenir la
décote jusqu'à 67 ans et pour supprimer
les régimes spéciaux de retraite bref
autant de reculs sociaux qui vont
pénaliser principalement les femmes les
précaires les seniors celles et ceux qui
ont des métiers pénibles et qui
favoriser le sentiment des jeunes qu'ils
n'auront pas max de retraite merci chers
collègues alors je vais consulter le
Sénat sur la motion tendante à opposé la
question préalable je rappelle que
l'adoption de cette motion entraînerait
le rejet du texte en discussion en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public ordinaire est de droit
et le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
alors je donne le résultat du scrutin
nombre de votants 343 exprimé 329 pour
la motion 264 contre 65 la motion est
adoptée et en conséquence le texte est
considéré comme rejeter alors je vais
suspendre la séance quelques instants
pour permettre à chacun de s'installer
pour l'examen du prochain point à
l'ordre du jour la séance est suspendue